- [Reporter] This is North
Korean state media footage
of leader Kim Jong-un from July last year.
(reporter speaking in Korean)
And this is him about a year later,
where he appears to look thinner.
Kim's weight loss has gotten
a lot of people alarmed.
From citizens.
(citizen speaking in Korean)
- [Reporter] And some north Korean experts
have raised questions
about his weight loss
and what that means for the Kim regime.
We don't know precisely why
Kim Jong-un has shed some pounds,
but what's clear is how Kim
Jong-un's thinner figure
is being used as propaganda
inside North Korea.
South Korean spy agency estimates believe
that Kim Jong-un has gained
about 14 pounds a year
since taking over as the country's leader
nearly a decade ago.
This weight gain is intentional.
North Koreans like their
leaders to be plump.
Also, Kim Jong-un has
tried to style himself,
both literally and figuratively,
like his grandfather Kim Il-sung,
who is revered across North Korea.
But these are tough
times for the Kim regime.
They're battling with the pandemic
but the regime has decided
to seal off its borders,
and that's created economic strife.
Certainly, sanctions still exist.
So Kim Jong-un at various meetings
has been urging his
citizens to sacrifice more,
to tighten their belts.
Kim Jong-un has mentioned
potential food shortages.
So the fact that Kim
Jong-un himself looks,
by his own standards, more gaunt,
this as a propaganda point can be used
to project to North Koreans
that Kim Jong-un is alongside
with the shared sacrifice,
that times are difficult for him too.
There is no topic that's more
off limits inside North Korea
than the leader's health.
Experts say the fact that state media,
which is heavily curated and orchestrated,
chose to run interviews
articulating concern for Kim Jong-un
because of his weight loss shows
that this is not a grave health concern
but rather perhaps a rallying call.
Experts say this is more of a message
to bolster spirits and to really reinforce
that Kim Jong-un is a
person for the people,
a leader for the people,
more so than an outward message.
But to the outside world,
this is yet another reminder
of where Kim Jong-un's
attention is at the moment.